at velasquez's 15th start
he's three and four 5.35 era
[Music]
swinging a foul tip and there's the
first strikeout for vince
runaway here in the first there goes
chisholm
pitch is taken for a ball before the
second on one hop he is
out at second base well done gino
zagora with the tag of the one hopper
it's been a while
since jt has thrown somebody out
it's a terrible i mean terrible jump
for the marlins and zach thompson this
will be his sixth major league start his
first start since july
fourth and there's paul four he just
walks segora on four pitches
and a base runner for the phillies just
like the marlins right out of the gate
that'll break bryce harper up our first
seven home run
16 runs batted in in his last 19 games
batting here with the rudder at first in
the bottom of the first
he broke his back ground ball to short
and off the glove of
rojas sagores racing everybody to the
bag and he wins
jean sigour is one of those guys his
baseball instinct his baseball iq
whatever you want to call it his engine
it's always on point
so the phillies have runners on the
corners and andrew mccutch in the battle
obviously know what's coming
that ball is drilled out to left center
field marte is going to track it down
tagging from third is segora he's going
to coast home
it's a sac fly for mccutchen
one nothing phillies
now rhys hoskins and a lighter out
toward right center field
that's going to split the gap and go to
the wall harper's to third he's being
waved home
hoskins to second and rbi double
two-nothing
phillies and he uses that side of the
field
he becomes so much of a better hitter
all right so they're taking a look at
the back of
vinnie's he's got a beetle or something
on him there we go
they're everywhere right now what are
they beetles
really they're all over the place do
they come with guitars on the same music
too
so with nobody out and one out here's
miguel rojas
falling two strikes and that one is
ripped down the left field line
mccutcheon will cut this one off miggy's
on his way to second
the throw is a little bit late it's
another double
for miguel rojas that'll bring up
sandy leone two to leone
swinging this tied him up with 94.
little up in the zone
got his third strikeout pretty good job
working around that one out double
zack thompson goes back to work here in
the bottom of the fourth inning
mccutchen to lead it off
that's a line drive and it's caught by
jazz
a leaping lunging play in the shallow
right to take a hit away from andrew
mccutchen
two-nothing ball game philly's looking
for more one out runners on the corners
leone sets him way outside this is a
ground ball to short
miggy turns the double play
so kerwin deadly waited as long as he
could it is an official ball game
just so everybody knows so they'll throw
the tarp on the field hopefully this is
a
quick shower vince velasquez
done after five innings and a delay and
hector neris is going to commit to the
ball game
in tuna duval
swing and a miss hector
back to back strikeouts high leverage
inning
no runs ahead one man left all right so
here's harper he reached on the error in
the first that led to the two runs
o2 pitch coming that one scoffed out
toward right center field duvall on the
run he won't get there it's going to be
one hop
or two hop off the wall as harper will
pull into second base his 16th double
okay reece doubled home around his first
time up
though under pitches call the ball
the throw to third not in time actually
let me correct it carolyn denley just
reiterated that it was a strike but it
is a stolen base eight steals for harper
without getting caught
coach had a sacrifice fly his first
at-bat
[Applause]
line drive out to left field a base hit
from mccutcheon
that'll move harper up to second
trying to sneak that cheese past cuts
ain't happening
against ranger suarez 25 year old's been
outstanding this season is now the
closer for the philadelphia
phillies marte one for three
ground ball through the right side a
base hit segura was
shaded up the middle a little bit on a
ball that wasn't necessarily hit all
that hard
so here we go bumping your safety belts
see if the marlins can't
get this ball game tied
aguilar left field this one is gone a
game tying
home run a two run shot for jesus
sagilar
asking you shall receive how about it
a changeup down in the zone
unloads williams has one home run
it's a fly ball to right field toward
the line diving play by
monte harrison
into the game to pinch run stays in and
makes a beautiful play on the right
field line
and kerwin deadly is going to put the
tarp on the field again
so in extra innings we are in another
delay our second delay of the night
is a big storm too wow
we fast forward to a gorgeous sunday
afternoon
where we have the finish of yesterday's
game
john birdie with the count one ball and
one strike will be the hitter
and a cult strike three on the inside
corner
who waited all this time during the
season and put it into the seats in
right
that's looped out to left that may be a
tough play here comes mccutchen he got
to the spot makes the catch
the inning is over some 14 hours later
the inning finally comes to a close reel
muto
at the plate fly ball right field this
should do it
going back is harrison it's going to do
it in a big way
out of the ballpark exclamation point
for real muto
in the fields a two-run home run
it took off and the phillies win it in
the 10th inning
four to two